-(applause and cheering)
-Welcome back!
Now, man, after witnessing
the full-blown circus
of the RNC last week, it's clear
that the future of the America
rests solely
in the hands
of Hillary Rodham Clinton.
Look, Hillary,
we are at a level red
apocalyptic (bleep) show.
(laughter)
And we desperately need you
to keep us from imploding
into the abyss, girl, all right?
-(applause and cheering)
-Listen to me, Hillary!
I'm serious, girl!
If you don't turn
this thing around,
Donald Trump could very well
be president!
-(laughter)
-People are nervous up in here!
-Yeah?
But I met someone at the White
House Correspondence dinner
who can give you some guidance.
Okay, so please welcome
The Nightly Show's
political campaign
strategy expert, DJ Khaled.
(applause and cheering)
Bless up. Bless up. It's time.
It's me, DJ Khaled.
You know me from Major Keys.
Major Keys, a success in
the music business and in life.
And I got Major Keys' selection,
the election to success
with Hillary Clinton.
So y'all ready for some keys?
(cheers and applause)
Major key number one.
♪ Number one?! ♪
You know Trump's
gonna fight dirty,
but if you come swinging
with that...
you know, that upper cut
and that boom knockout,
you're going to be all right.
♪ Number two! ♪
Hillary, you're a boss now.
When you're in the White House,
this time
you're not just the First Lady.
You're not just
the Secretary of State.
You're the number one!
You are that special...
♪ Cloth, cloth, cloth, cloth. ♪
Major key...
♪ Number three! ♪
♪ Win, win, win
no matter what! ♪
Getting endorsed by Barack--
that's my guy!
That's the dawn.
(applause and cheering)
And that's a major key!
But a little Cîroc to take
the edge off is a nice vibe!
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
♪ Bonus key! ♪
DJ Khaled,
the king of the anthems,
the king of Snapchat,
is officially endorsing...
Hillary Clinton...
(cheers and applause)
...to be the president
of the United States of America.
We the best.
DJ Khaled, major key in Hillary.
Do me a favor.
You can go to iTunes right now
and pre-order my album.
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
And it comes out July 29.
Hillary, that's a major key!
-(applause and cheering) -I had
a feeling that'd be major key.
DJ Khaled, everyone!
We'll be right back!
(cheers and applause)